[Música]
todo mundo aqui tem um sonho difícil de
realizar
sabe aqueles sonhos impossíveis que
ninguém acredita só quem sonha sabe que
é possível
eu ea diana três anos atrás tivemos um
desses sonhos impossíveis que foi ser a
primeira equipe de televisão a dar a
volta ao mundo para fazer 80 videoclips
só que a gente não tinha dinheiro nenhum
time não tinha dinheiro pra contratar
uma equipe não tinha dinheiro para
alugar equipamento não tinha nada a
gente até tentou ir atrás de algum
patrocinador mas obviamente ninguém
acreditou no nosso sonho e essa foi a
grande pedra que a gente tropeçou no
meio do caminho
mas não foi só no nosso caminho que
apareceu uma pedra em 1879
em mais um dia de trabalho o carteiro
francês ferdinand cheval caminhava pela
estrada uma pedra bem no meio do seu
caminho o derrubou
literalmente dessa vez essa pedra
poderia ter sido um problema no seu dia
mas na verdade ela lhe deu uma idéia
melhor
o ideal é juntar as pedras que ele
encontrasse pelo caminho e construir um
castelo bem no meio do seu quintal
só que para construir esse castelo que
ele queria
seriam necessárias milhares de pedras e
algumas décadas de trabalho
mas se a gente tivesse olhado com aquela
pedra que a gente confessou não como um
problema ou impedimento para realizar
nosso sonho mas a gente tivesse olhado
ela como uma oportunidade exatamente
como carteiro fez então é vamos fazer um
projeto com a ajuda de gente do mundo
inteiro se a gente não tem dinheiro pra
contratar pessoas para trabalhar pra
gente
vamos chamar as pessoas para trabalhar
com a gente e quem sabe essas pessoas
não poderiam ser essas pedrinhas que não
construíram se castelo foi exatamente
isso que a gente fez
e assim a gente criou esse projeto que a
gente se orgulha de mais totalmente
colaborativo chamado a volta ao mundo em
80 videoclips uma rede de pessoas
fazendo o impossível ser possível
inclusive que nos levou até a afirma um
desses clipes nesse lugar que agora já é
bastante conhecido de vocês
o palácio de pedras do francês
exatamente e foi no palace ideal que a
nossa história se cruzam quando o
carteiro por 18 meses a gente juntou
pessoas que tinham algo que a gente
precisava e que queriam algo que a gente
tinha para oferecer a troca entre
centenas de pessoas uma diferente da
outra
assim como as pedras do carteiro o
carteiro valor em algo que inicialmente
não tinha valor nenhum pedras e
transformou essas pedras em um objeto
valioso um palácio e se vocês estão
vendo aqui
sem essas pedras o carteiro não teria
construído o que hoje é considerado uma
das maiores obras da arquitetura na esf
sem as mais de mil pessoas a gente não
teria realizado o nosso sonho é o maior
projeto das nossas vidas mas a gente
olha para essas duas histórias que ela
nos ensina
primeiro a gente anda sempre ocupado e
dedicado a realizar nossos sonhos e é
realmente incrível quando a gente
consegue agora essas duas histórias
mostra uma outra coisa que a gente não
pára pra prestar atenção a gente não
enxerga que cem pedras não existe
castelo
será que a gente às vezes não se esquece
um pouco disso
será que a gente não se esquece que a
gente pode ser a pedra que falta para o
castelo de alguém e eu acho que é essa
nossa mensagem aqui é isso que a gente
aprendeu nesses anos para mais sonhos
serem realizados
alguém com certeza precisa exatamente o
que você tem para oferecer
brigada
[Aplausos]